we are going to begin with the latest
from Southern California that horrific
mass shooting on Saturday night the
victims were celebrating the Lunar New
Year at a dance studio in Monterey Park
when the gunman came in at least 10
people killed more in the hospital as we
speak and police say the suspect took
his own life after officers approached
him in a white van yesterday our lead
National correspondent David begno heads
our coverage from this heartbroken
community of Monterey Park David this is
a tough one to make sense of a night
that should have been about celebration
instead this tragedy good morning
Tony good morning to give you some
context this is a town of roughly 60 000
people at about two-thirds of the people
who live here are Asian yesterday marked
the start of the Lunar New Year which is
widely celebrated in East Asian cultures
particularly in China where it is
considered the most important holiday
now I'm standing in downtown Monterey
Park right off the strip here in
downtown is the dance studio police have
cleared the scene taken back all the
police tapes and that's the entrance
right there where you see those candles
and the flowers the sheriff says most of
the victims here were either middle-aged
or elderly
what started as a night of music and
dancing for these patrons inside the
star ballroom dance studio
units requested multiple victims guns
out wounds turned into a nightmare
gunshots rang out around 10 20 p.m
Saturday night and I got approximately
10 to these police say the gunman
entered the venue and opened fire
killing 10 people and injuring 10 others
suddenly heard
Hattie Pung was there as the shooting
broke out she says several people around
her were killed you will see the body
already several lying there her dance
partner seen here in this video during a
Christmas party shielded her during the
barrage of bullets but he was struck
twice in the process and rushed to the
hospital he's my hero oh he's he's uh I
own him he covered me Witnesses said the
suspect Who police described as an adult
Asian man then fled the scene the LA
County Sheriff said 20 to 30 minutes
later that same gunman entered another
ballroom dance studio about three miles
away in the city of Alhambra there
bystanders were able to wrestle the gun
away from him police say Witnesses saw
the gunman then flee in a white van
police later released an image of the
suspect about 12 hours after the first
shooting police spotted the suspect
inside that same white van with a
different license plate this time more
than 20 miles away that was in the city
of Torrance when officers exited their
patrol vehicle to contact the occupant
they heard one gunshot then police
surrounded the van armored vehicles
moved in bomb squad trucks too they're
breaking the window there you go they
broke these broke the window Dead Inside
was 72 year old who can Tran the sheriff
said he took his own life several pieces
of evidence were found inside the van
linking the suspect to both locations
and Monterey Park in Alhambra today was
supposed to be a happy nice day for
everyone to enjoy Saturday night
shooting in Monterey Park took place
during the wildly popular Lunar New Year
celebrations in a city that is more than
60 percent Asian I feel this sense of
great loss about the home that I always
had it's just it's just gone I'll never
be able to feel safe here again
the gun recovered at the second crime
scene was a semi-automatic assault
pistol with an extended large capacity
magazine which the L.A County Sheriff
said he believes is not legal in the
state of California
yesterday I spoke with congresswoman
Judy Chu she represents this area she is
a former mayor here at Monterey Park we
were at the crime scene with her when
news broke that the suspect was dead
what was your initial reaction when you
were told what happened and how horrific
it was
I could not believe the extent of the
violence ten people dead
this was one of the worst mass shootings
in L.A county and one of the worst in
the nation
and I was also outraged because there
are far too many of these mass shootings
going on we have to take actions to make
sure that people are safe in America I
have joined the gun safety caucus in
Congress and we have worked on
legislation that should have passed a
long time ago such as on the universal
background checks which have proven to
take guns out of dangerous people's
hands I want to say to those who are
resistant to these gun safety laws
protect America Protect your fellow
neighbors you don't know if the next
person could be your loved one
and yet we know there are concrete
Common Sense steps that we can take to
stop all this terrible and senseless
violence
why do we have so many guns in this
country and even more on the horizon
it's not right other countries don't
operate this way and we should not
either
the police chief here in Monterey Park
said yesterday that the first officers
who responded to the scene were rookies
they had only been on the job for a
couple of months they had never seen
such a horrific scene like this he said
they went in immediately they didn't
wait they entered the building and
that's when they spotted the Carnage
inside
CBS reports correspondent Adam Yamaguchi
is here with me now Adam you grew up in
this area this is home for you I know
you were talking with people last night
what did you hear and give us a sense of
the report you'll have at the bottom of
the hour 7 30. so there's a real sense
there's a real mix of of sadness sadness
mixed with a sense of disbelief
um you just introduced us to Hattie pong
who survived the shooting and when I
interviewed her she said that she hasn't
been able to sleep and she told us that
the dance studio is uh sort of a refuge
and not only for her but for many other
senior Asian Americans here and I'll
have more with Hattie and other
community members in our next half hour
Adam thank you thank you for being here
you know Gales I toss it back to you in
New York I'm reminded of what the
sheriff said yesterday he said here in
California we have some of the strictest
gun laws yet this still happened and he
ended his press conference by saying the
status quo as it pertains to gun laws is
just not working
I don't know how many times we have to
tell this story I like what Adam said
sadness just belief and let's please add
anger to this too David thank you so
much